a new wave of innovation is fueling a
radical change in fashion wearable
technology data automation and lab-grown
materials will have a major impact on
what people will be wearing in the
future we are just seeing a pace of
change which is frightening but it's
also incredibly exciting for the future
of fashion
[Music]
since the birth of sewing and weaving
technology has always led developments
in fashion the Industrial Revolution
mechanized manufacturing enabling mass
production in the 1960s synthetic
materials like polyester took off
creating new possibilities for fashion
now the convergence of new technologies
is opening up previously unimaginable
possibilities self-styled fashion
scientist dr. Amanda Parkes is in the
vanguard of the industry's latest
reinvention she heads up innovation at
Ft labs a venture capital firm that
invests primarily in disruptive fashion
tech startups the future of fashion is a
mixture of combining new material
technologies with all new forms of
business models among these startups the
race is on to find the next generation
of renewable materials that can be grown
in a lab so one example of this is bolt
threads which creates loud groan spider
silk traditional silk is produced from
insect larvae that form cocoons
most commonly silkworms but rather than
relying on these insects bolt threads is
creating silk in test tubes so they've
taken the DNA out of a spider just the
part of the DNA that creates silk and
transform that into a microorganism into
a yeast and you can think of it like
brewing beer so as they feed the yeast
as it brews it creates silk protein bio
fabricated materials remove the need for
animals and insects and they are a more
sustainable and efficient way of
producing raw materials
you're able to speed up this process put
it into a controlled environment in the
laboratory and have a lot more control
over what you're growing and how other
companies are creating leather
alternatives rather than using animals
scientists are creating bio fabricated
materials from pineapple leaves and even
mushrooms another example is a mycelium
based leather so the root structure of
strains of mushrooms can be grown
synthetically in a lab but they're all
natural fibers when you think about the
convergence of what technology can do
with this in terms of the future
development of materiality and so we
really have the opportunity to make huge
global change by changing the means of
production of materials the convergence
of fashion and technology also provides
opportunities to transform not just
clothes but the people wearing them
Mayon is a company that's pioneering the
creation of clothing that can monitor
your every move we call it textile
computing some other people call it the
smart fabric
essentially it's a is an interactive
fabric that could sense data from you so
called smart fabrics are being touted as
the next frontier of wearable technology
yarns are paired with electronic sensors
so that essential data can be captured
from the human body this is a men's
boxer you can see the sensors embedded
on the band and on the body within
seconds it will start transmitting your
ECG temperature your movement your
respiration to create clothing that can
monitor the wearer's health and fitness
my aunt has brought together teams of
people that have not traditionally
worked under the same roof we have the
advanced research engineers and
scientists at nano scale technology
electrical engineers mechatronics
engineers software AI we wanted them to
interface and to interact with fashion
designers with pattern makers smart
fabrics could radically change consumers
relationships with the clothes they wear
but as technology increases the pace of
change how can the industry keep track
of what consumers really want
[Music]
Franchesca Mustang is the head of retail
at WGSN the world's leading fashion
forecasting agency we are just seeing a
pace of change which is frightening but
it's also incredibly exciting to the
future of fashion the staff here use big
data to analyze political social and
environmental trends in order to predict
the hot new looks of tomorrow if we
think back over the last five years how
the fashion industry has changed think
about the way that we shop compared to
the way that we used to shop technology
is driving an explosion in consumer
choice as well as the bewildering array
of clothing design and creation to keep
up the industry is also turning to
technology we are for sure in the midst
of a digital revolution AI the idea of
kind of machine learning and Big Data
how do we start to sort of synthesize
all of these new technologies and start
to make sense of it both in terms of
industry but also in terms of the
consumer machine learning technologies
are now central to fashion forecasting
quickly spotting patterns among the
ever-growing volume of data from
biotechnology to demographic shifts
predicting trends is no longer an art
it's becoming a science